we can't emphasize enough when you do
this colonoscopy the the search is for a
polyp these polyps when you find them
are generally benign however they can be
the kind of polyp which over time can
turn into cancer and if you take the
polyp out at that time which you can do
during the colonoscopy instead of
potentially getting cancer you don't get
cancer so I know people don't like to do
the prep but it's really really people
might be listening and thinking to
themselves it can't be that simple but
you are saying that it is that exactly
they think it can't be that but you're
right about the stigma you know it's one
of the first jokes between parents and
their kids right it's something to have
having to do with pooping or peeing
right and then for years we can't we
don't talk about it and I I love taboo
for some reason it's taboo but I love
that that you know you were able to talk
about it get out Ryan Reynolds did it
did it on air and of course Katie Kirk
all those years back and it's really
important to get the get the word out